hundreds of volunteers have been working
long days to collect sort pack and ship
urgently needed help for earthquake
victims in turkey and Syria in the last
few months they have been collecting
humanitarian aid for civilians in
Russian held eastern Ukraine as soon as
the earthquake happened they launched an
appeal for help
things are brought in by everyone people
like you and me bring in all they have I
know a lot of people who brought two
jackets out of the three they had and
only kept one as soon as they found out
about the travel in turkey and Syria
everyone responded donors here are
Ordinary People not the wealthy
the volunteers have gathered in the
basement of moscow's largest mosque the
Charities here run the zakat fund a
fundraising platform to help those in
need regardless of their faith or
location
the oldest volunteer here is 90 one of
as many as 500 people doing what they
can for the earthquake victims
pakistanis chechnyans kha'zix tatters
have all come together to help
58 Nations and ethnic groups make up the
20 million or so Muslims in Russia and
thousands have come to help the people
of Syria and turkey and it's not just
Muslims inside the mosque who are
helping out
Karina is an Orthodox Christian and is
supervising the volunteer teams the
whole day during 14 hours and at the end
of the day I have a lot of energy I had
a lot of energy and I can't understand
why there are so hot and a lot of Duties
and a lot of people but these people are
unusual for me they are so kind oh sorry
I don't want to cry
um
many here get emotional talking about
the plight of the victims and the
dedication of the volunteers they say
they understand the scale of the
disaster and will continue to collect
much needed a date for the victims
Moscow